You don't fight,
your friends fights.
Really? Why do you?
I will tell you everything.
You have to come with me for a few hours.
She's not here anymore.
You follow the rules.
You become an officer.
We're the only thing
holding this all together.
You trust me, right?
Open your eyes.
Tonight, I'm going to show you
the four wonders of the mall.
None of this is even about me.
If you come back,
we could be running things.
We're like the future.
You're a firefly.
Yes, Ellie.
Put it down.
And get ready to run.
Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my last of us
Episode 7 Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references to the game,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway
for HBO Max Subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post all your predictions
on the trailer.
Careful for spoilers for the episode
so far if you haven't caught up yet.
But the trailer is basically telling us
Ellie's back story.
The title of the episode Left Behind is a
reference to the DLC from the first game.
It's like a DLC episode.
People have been joking all about.
Ellie's back story is primarily
focused on Ellie and Riley, the person
that she keeps referring to
in previous episodes, the people, quote
unquote, that she's lost, the people
that she's left behind, so to speak.
Everybody I have cared for
has either died or left me.
I'm sorry about your daughter, Joel,
but I have lost people, too.
You have no idea what loss is.
Everyone I have cared
for has either died or left me.
You remember at the end of episode 6,
the big cliffhanger they had is that Joel
seemed like he was getting ready to die.
Like he started bleeding out
after his fight with the Raiders.
She basically has to take care of Joel
because they're way too far away
from Tommy's
settlement for her to just take him back.
So you see why it was so important for her
to show that she had all these skills
previously in the episode
and why it was important
for Joel to teach her how to shoot,
because now she has to hunt.
The both of them can eat.
There was a brief time jump in the game
after they picked up Joel and like after
he's injured and she drags him away
to recover in shelter.
Then there's a short time
jump as he starts to get better.
But it seems like what the show has done
is that they're actually going a flashback
to Ellie's backstory.
There might be a moment,
the beginning of the episode
or the end of the episode just to address
what happened last week
or what's happening next week.
But I'm assuming for the most part,
the entire episode will
mostly take place
in a flashback to her backstory.
A lot of the trailer details
the events of their adventure
to the abandoned shopping mall,
which you referenced to Joel earlier.
Like I never Elisabeth's in
quarantine zone except for that one time.
She never really fully explained it.
But this is what that was her leaving
the quarantine zone
to go to this cordoned off
mall area Bradley took her to.
And this is meant to be the events
of Riley's death that traumatized her
even more than she already was,
like more traumatized
than she would already be,
just living in the apocalypse,
trying to survive day to day
under those terrible conditions
that everyone lived under
when she's getting ready to open the door.
Looks all traumatized already.
I'm not sure when this moment is happening
because so many things happened to her
during her back story.
This could be a number of different
things.
Is there training in the fedra school?
She talked about this
previously inside the Boston
quarantine zone,
the other quarantine zones.
Phaedra had a system for all the children
where they would give them
basic education.
And it seems like their whole point,
like Fedra's whole plan was to just
onboard them
and train them to become fedra soldiers.
This is kind of similar to
what happened in the Star Wars universe
when the Empire took over.
Like Phaedra.
Terrible empire, also terrible.
But part of the idea in The Last of Us is
that there are some fairly decent people
working in Phaedra,
like the person that she's talking
to about making it through school.
Like Luke, you train,
you become part of Phaedra.
Were the dominating force here.
This is the best
option for your future work
for the most powerful group in the area.
It's basically what the empire told people
after the events of Revenge of the Sith,
after the rise of the Empire.
You'd have Imperials on
pretty much every planet,
just sort of drumming people into service,
putting out all this propaganda.
Like the Empire's wonderful.
Come help us make the Empire.
Even better, when really,
they're actually pretty terrible.
And that's the whole idea in
the Last of Us Fedra
is meant to be pretty terrible,
like the conditions
that people live under.
Even though Fedra is trying to help,
people are terrible.
The fireflies are meant to be
their biggest opposition,
and they're meant to be the good group,
so to speak, even though they do
a lot of terrible things too.
The whole idea is that the fireflies
want to get rid of Fedra
and install a civilian government.
Fedra is more of like a military type
of government.
Really.
They're more like FEMA
in the United States,
like a disaster
response agency backed by the government.
If they were on steroids
and took control of the regular military
like there is no real U.S.
president or anything like that,
like there's
no cabinet, there's no Congress
or anything like that in the apocalypse.
They're just fedra in their regular
militaristic organization.
So, like, you have squad
commanders, you have administrators,
you have generals, that kind of stuff
in, for the most part, each quarantine
zone kind of takes care of their own.
They don't worry too much about
what's happening in other quarantine.
Those they're couple
quarantine zones
that handle the manufacture
of a lot of really important
drugs and medicines.
Otherwise, most of the quarantine zones
just worry about what's happening
in their own quarantined zone area.
You notice when she's running around this
basketball court here, all the banners
stop at 2003 because of the fungus.
It was the same in Tommy's town, too.
Like, there's a banner that reads 23,
like Culture Froze in 2003.
Lot of people asking
if the girl with the braids
that's picking on Ellie,
picking the fight with her is Abby.
That's probably not the case
because she's the daughter
of one of the Firefly doctors
living in Salt
Lake City
during the events of the first game,
meaning he either retreated there
with the fireflies
from the research facility
that they literally just visited,
or he was always the doctor living in Salt
Lake City, working there normally
in after the fungus just started
working with the fireflies there.
So Abby would have had to have grown up
in those places on the West Coast.
And Ellie grew up in the Boston
quarantine zone on the East Coast.
And if you haven't played the game,
she was born in the Boston Quarantine
zone.
We'll probably see the events of her birth
at some point, too,
because we do see it in the trailer.
And there's another video game cameo
from Ashley Johnson, who plays her mother.
She played Ellie in the games.
It's kind of like Troy Baker cameo ing
as part of the cannibals in the future.
Episode two.
Troy Baker plays Joel in the games.
I think these scenes are just meant
to give you a vibe of what
her life was like living with Riley
before she learned she was immune.
That didn't happen
until a little bit later.
Will be the end of the episode.
Basically. Riley is from the video games.
Like I said, most of this episode is taken
from the Last of Us DLC.
That's why the title of the episode
is called The Last of Us.
She's played by Storm Reid that a lot of
people recognize from other places.
We find out that Riley joined
the Fireflies in search to explain to her
what's going on with Marlene in the
Fireflies mission to try and save society.
Basically.
And it sounds like
she finds the abandoned mall
because of her work with the fireflies
going outside the quarantine zone.
It wants to show Ellie
just because they're so close.
Like they're very, very close friends.
Which is why Riley's death
was so traumatic to her.
They actually feature this shot
in all the trailers
with her looking at the mall
all lit up at night.
They explained that Ellie planned
to become part of Pedro.
Like she tells Riley, You could come back.
We could run things when we get older.
That's the whole idea in Riley
trying to explain to her.
No, no, no.
The fireflies are where it's at.
Like they have a better plan
than Pedro has.
It's kind of like Joel's arc in the way
that he sees the value
of the Fireflies plan, but still doesn't
really like them that much.
Ellie, for instance, does like the idea
of potentially saving the human race.
But it's not like she loves
the idea of the fireflies.
They're just like another option
that seems a little bit better
than the fedra option.
Joel In present day, for example,
still kind of hates the fireflies
as much as he hates Fedra.
He really wants to avoid
both organizations if he can.
Even Tommy just split with the fireflies,
which Joel was really happy
about when he learned.
It looks like what they're trying to say
in the episode.
Ellie starts
setting off all these pipe bombs
and going crazy, creating all this noise
and that alerts the clickers nearby.
And it sounds like that
leads to Riley's death eventually.
One of the ways that she eventually learns
that she is immune is because
they get attacked by an infected
and she gets injured and does not turn.
That's the whole idea
in the first couple of episodes,
when Joel starts
to learn about her immunity to,
he doesn't totally believe it,
but like he literally sees that she hasn't
turned after a couple of days
go by the events
of what happened with Riley, her
in her learning about her immunity weren't
that long ago is relatively recently
before the events of episode one.
That's why she looks exactly the same,
like they didn't bother to do
or anything like that.
And it seems like what they're saying here
is that Riley tried to protect her
and she gets injured and winds up
turning in.
Part of the idea is that
Ellie is forced to kill her
or be killed by Riley, theoretically,
which is why she's so traumatized
by this event.
Like normally she'd be traumatized
because her friend died.
Like, that's bad enough already.
But it's the sheer fact that at this
younger age, slightly younger than in
present day, she's forced to kill
the best friend that she's ever had.
Like the only person in the world
right now that she's close to.
Because even though
Marlene is a big person in her life
during the first couple of episodes,
she's not really close to Marlene
that way.
And at least up until the events
of the first couple of episodes
or like right
before the first couple of episodes,
she doesn't know Marlene that well,
even though Marlene explains
that sees the person
that put her in fedra school
to keep her safe temporarily
until she got old enough
to take care of herself
or doing the fireflies normally.
It'll be interesting to see where they
in this episode if they flashback
to present day just to pick up with her
in Joel in present day,
or if they just wait to episode
eight to do that.
Everyone posts all your predictions
in the comments below.
My full Episode seven video
will post Sunday after they release it.
There's a whole bunch other stuff
coming the next couple of weeks.
The Mandalorian Season three episodes
are also starting in a couple of weeks
too, so it'll be a bunch of Pedro
Pascal crossover for a couple of weeks.
Pedro Pascal into the past.
Alba's
The funny thing about The Mandalorian
is that his relationship with Grogu
is very similar to Pedro
Pascal's relationship with the Ellie
character in The Last of Us.
He means more to me
than you will ever know,
Dad. Like figure taking care of helpless
young child.
Even though technically Grogu
isn't helpless, he's
meant to be one of the most powerful
characters of the Star Wars
universe in Ellie
is starting to get better and better,
hunting on her own, surviving on her own.
So she's not completely helpless either.
There was a brand New Mandalorian Season
3 trailer that was just released.
I'll do a video for that next.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
Everyone click here for my Last of Us
episode videos and click here
for my New Mandalorian Season 3 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone. Stay safe.
This is the way.